[Music]
your stand-up you've got a lot of
experience you perform a lot for crowds
do you ever get nervous anymore in front
of a big crowd is any situation make you
a little intimidated no I I don't really
get nervous III I mean you get like like
specific instances I'll get nervous like
I had a I showed up at the Laugh actor
once and I was a packed house which is
normal a lot of times I place a pack but
Bieber came Justin Bieber Justin Bieber
yeah and Daryl Daryl Eber George Beaver
yeah none of those other Bieber's right
right it sounds like an agent from the
50s yeah no so I showed up and they were
like hey hey come here
like everybody the club I'll be like
work there what's up really you know
who's here huh and I said what he said
Bieber's here I said all right cool and
he said yeah yeah but he's here to see
you and I was like oh okay okay so I
went up and and I really you know it's
like nerve I mean the kids 18 but he's
also the king so so I did it I went up
and I know I know his thing as I never
say never but I never performed that
hard in my life because you tried really
hard I tried really hard really really
hard and and afterwards he just he came
up to me and he was like hey man you did
a great job and this ho sounds looking
guy yeah look I was like pulling up his
pants and just hey man you did a great
job and I was like oh it's impossible to
talk to him without flirting do you know
what I mean sure I mean I you know what
I'm looking I'm a good job and I was
like
you're silly but I just really I love
your stuff and but uh and then all of
his buddies were like yeah yeah dude
we've been fenced they all sounded that
way
yeah his entourage doesn't travel with
one of his entire entourage is sucking
on helium yeah Ninja Turtles that's the
lollipop right old it sounds like yeah
we've been fans of yours for a while and
I was like oh cool oh cool awesome I'm
gonna be part of your guys's crew now
okay and no and so he so then they all
tweeted about me that entourage
yeah the entourage but not him and I was
like oh man bittersweet you know I mean
cuz it's all of his guys are Wow he
tweeted exactly and I'm like you know
maybe tweeted about me you know but then
uh
but the next morning I tweeted something
and then right away he rolled back do
you have it I think you have to have it
yeah so you didn't have time for the why
oh no I know
they're brilliant kill them yeah what a
wildly old it was in a hurry real hurry
you did get the a re yeah let's get you
our that's true true that means he
really does like you yeah but I got why
oh you are quite hilarious to him from
him yeah really
indubitably that's what he wrote me he
just had a lot of time just nice maybe
but ya know when I woke up the morning
and everyone was like you got tweeted by
Justin and I was like huh and I was just
jumping around in my bed naked you know
we all do so but yeah so imparted
Bieber's crew now I don't care what
anybody says
and if I know he's been like punching
people lately yeah maybe you could treat
him a little nicer do you know what I
mean
[Music]
maybe society it's time so maybe it's
society's yeah go get him Justin bunch
of mall